We need stories.
We need stories to
understand ourselves.
We are the only creature
that does this unusual thing
of telling each other
stories in order
to try and understand the
kind of creature that we are.
When a child is born, the
first thing the child requires
is safety and love.
The next thing that the child
asks for is, "Tell me a story."
I've been writing now
for over 50 years.
And this is the first time
I've done anything like this.
You will learn the
lessons I had to find out
the hard way-- character,
plot, dialogue, rhythm.
I do think language
has a musicality.
There's all this stuff
about three-act structure,
exactly how you must
allow a story to unfold.
My view is it's all nonsense.
The first and only
rule is be interesting.
Make it as vivid as you can.
Bam!
As an exercise, write
300 words about the place
without using any adjectives.
If you can't say that somewhere
is beautiful or green, what
it forces you to do is
to tell a story about it.
I'm going to read
from this manuscript I
wrote in my mid 20s.
It was a failure, so much
so that I never showed it
to anybody until this.
(The sky is nude today,
encasing his documentary
in a very un-February
blue.) You see,
I don't even know
what that's about.
I had a very bumpy start.
And to be frank, I
wrote a lot of garbage.
Part of the reason
why I was lost
is that I had grown
up in one culture
and I was living in another.
And I didn't quite understand
my relationship with either.
I really needed to
work out who I was,
because if you're not
clear about who you are,
then you're not clear
about how to write.
Whatever you write,
write because it
comes from some very
deep place inside you
that you really, really,
really need to express.
Just make sure that you don't
stop till you get to the end.
I'm Salman Rushdie, and
this is my MasterClass.